The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: Good morning.
I want to start today's lecture
with, I guess one
could call it, a confession.
This isn't a real
6.00 lecture.
I'm standing here on June 30th
in an empty classroom dressed,
for some bizarre reason,
as if it's the winter.
I guess it's what the video
folks would call continuity.
What happened is Professor
Grimson gave a beautiful
lecture 13, for which we have a
lovely picture and no sound.
We decided that probably those
of you watching this in
OpenCourseWare would be
unhappy just to watch
Professor Grimson and not hear
him, so we're now re-taping
the lecture.
This is, actually, one of two
lectures we're going to be
re-taping because we
had video problems.
So when I say something
hilariously funny, and there
is no laughter in
the room, it's
because the room is empty.
Do me a favor and laugh out
there in video-land, so maybe
at least someone will respond.
OK, the last lecture closed with
a slight mystery, not a
great mystery, but
a little mystery.
We ran our simulation of the
drunkard's walk and got a
result that wasn't credible.
How did we know it
wasn't credible?
Well we had worked out some
details on the blackboard of
what we thought would happen
with a small number of steps,
and the results we got
didn't match that.
That told us we had
something wrong.
We asked you to go think about
it and come back today
prepared to tell us
what was wrong.
Well since there is no one here
to ask, I'm not going to
ask the class to fix it, but
instead I have had the
laborious task of fixing
it myself.
So let's look at it.
The problem was in SimWalk.
And what we had is we had
the wrong argument here.
We had numTrials Instead
of numSteps.
And so it didn't
make any sense.
I've now fixed it, and I,
now, want to run it.
Well clearly, what I should do
to begin with, is run it on
some examples for which we
already know the answer.
So I'll change drunkTest to
instead of running it on large
numbers of steps, run
it on just a few.
And let's see what we get.
We run a lot of trials here,
since it's a short trial.
And what we see is for 100
trials of 0 steps, the mean
was 0, the max was
0, the min was 0.
Well that's exactly what
we saw when we looked
at it on the board.
It should happen.
And the same thing with 1.
Everything worked the way
it was supposed to work.
It doesn't tell us the
program is perfect.
It does tell us it works in at
least two examples, which was
better than we had last time.
All right now let's look at it
on a larger set of examples.
I think I won't run 100 trials
here, because it'll take a
little longer than we want.
So let's run maybe 20.
Let's see what we get.
Well it's running
through here.
Now we're getting examples that
seem much more credible.
When we take 10 steps, the mean
is 2.85, and the max is
between 6 and 1, or the max
is 6, the min is 1.
It's what we would hope
for, that there's
some dispersion there.
And as we get up higher, we see
that for a 100,000 steps,
the mean is 248, and there's
quite a spread between the max
and the min.
Finally we get to look at the
question that had us writing
this code in the first place--
how far should we expect this
drunk to be, given a
particular amount of time.
Well we can look at these
numbers and try and think
about them in our heads, but in
fact, it's a lot easier to
look at a picture.
And this will get us to a theme
that we'll be getting to
shortly in the course of how
do we visualize data.
So here we have a
visualization.
What I'm plotting, here, is the
mean number of the mean
distance against the number of
steps for this random walk.
And what we can see is, as we
knew, at 0, it's 0, and then
it sort of goes up.
And I've taken it only
up to a 1,000.
And at 1,000 we're somewhere,
it looks
like, around 25 steps.
So we can learn something.
Well what can we learn
from this?
How fast is it growing?
Well it seems to grow
pretty fast, and
then it flattens out.
It looks to me like, roughly
speaking, the distance is
growing as sort of close
to the square root of
the number of steps.
Well I could look at
it more closely.
We, actually, know this is not
exactly the square root.
Right, the square root of a
1,000 is not going to be 25,
but I'm not going to delve
into the details of that.
It's, actually, a little
bit complicated.
We could derive it, but we
won't, because I want to get
to what I think is a more
important message.
How much should we infer from
this or from the numbers I
displayed before, and I want
to say not too much.
Because what we saw, if we go
look at what we had before, is
quite a dispersion between
the max and the min.
And furthermore, if we run it
again, the 20 trials, we're
getting different answers.
So what you can see, here, is
for 10,000 steps, here, my
mean was 78, and here, for
10,000 steps, my mean is 90.
Here, the mean was 279.
Here, it was 248.
The maxs and the mins
are different.
So I don't want to read too
much into that graph.
Now one of the issues we should
have asked is, well
it's the mean of how
many trials.
I didn't tell you.
And to be honest, I don't
quite remember.
I think it was 20.
But I don't have enough
information to interpret it.
I need a lot more and that's
going to be what this whole
next unit of the course is about
is how do we think about
the results of programs when
the programs themselves are
stochastic.
And this is important because,
as you will see, not only in
this course, but as you progress
in your careers, if
you're involved in engineering
or science, is that almost
everything in the real
world is stochastic.
And in order to think about it,
we have to really think
pretty hard about what
those things mean.
So I want to, now, pull back
and talk a little bit, sort
of, philosophically about
that, about the role of
randomness in computation--
something you probably haven't
seen a lot, if at all in the
other courses you've taken
if you're a freshman or
sophomore, and that's because
there's something really
comforting about Newtonian
mechanics.
When I first learned physics,
it was really comforting.
I learn the physics
of Isaac Newton.
You push down on one end of the
lever, the other end of
the lever goes up.
You throw a ball up in the air,
it travels a parabolic
path and lands.
F equals MA, that wonderful
rule of physics.
Everything happened
for a reason.
It was predictable.
It was a great comfort to
some of us about it.
And for centuries, that's the
way the world thought, from
almost the beginning of the
times of science to, really,
if you look at history of
science, to today, people
believed the world was
deterministic.
And they liked it.
Then along came the so-called
Copenhagen Doctrine and
quantum physics in the 20th
century, and the comforting
world of Newtonian physics
disappeared.
The Doctrine, the Copenhagen
Doctrine, led by the
physicists Bohr and Heisenberg,
argued that at its
most predictable and most
fundamental level, the
behavior of the physical world
cannot be predicted.
One can make probabilistic
statements of the form x is
highly likely to occur, but not
statements of the form x
is certain to occur--
period.
I can make the probabilistic
statement that if I take this
laser pointer and put
it on the table,
it won't fall through.
The molecules won't separate
in such a nice way that it
just drops through, but I can't
promise it won't happen.
Truth is I'm going to make that
promise anyway, because I
believe in probability, and it's
highly, highly probable.
But they tried to say that,
in fact, the world is all
stochastic.
Everything is probabilistic.
Other distinguished physicists
at the time, most notably
Einstein and Schrodinger,
vehemently disagreed.
This debate, it's hard to
believe, actually, roiled the
world of physics, philosophy,
and religion.
The heart of the debate was
the validity of something
called causal non-determinism.
The idea here--
causal means caused by
previous events.
So causal non-determinism was
the belief that not every
event is caused by
previous events.
Einstein and Schrodinger found
this view philosophically
unacceptable, as exemplified
by Einstein's often quoted
comment, "God does
not play dice."
What they argued is for
something called predictive
non-determinism.
The concept here was that our
inability to make accurate
measurements about the physical
world makes it
impossible to make precise
predictions about the future.
So this distinction was nicely
summed up again by Einstein,
who said, and I quote, "the
essentially statistical
character of contemporary
theory is solely to be
ascribed to the fact that this
theory operates with an
incomplete description of
physical systems," i.e.,
things are not unpredictable,
they just look unpredictable
because we don't know enough
about the initial states.
This question is still
unsettled in science.
The good news is it probably
doesn't matter at all
what the truth is.
However you want to look at it,
we have to assume that the
world is non-deterministic,
because we can't, actually,
predict it.
So there's a little experiment
I sometimes do.
I'll pretend to do it,
even though there
are no students here.
I take three coins--
see if there are students in the
class, I ask the students
to give me coins, and then
I try to steal them.
But since there are no students,
I'm going to have to
use my own coins, and I'm going
to ask, is at least one
of them heads.
Well the truth is, it's
completely predictable.
I know the answer.
But you don't know the
answer, because you
can't see these coins.
And so you might as well assume
it's probabilistic, and
guess well, he put 3 coins down
at random, the odds of
each one being a head is
1/2, so probably 1
of the 3 is a head.
And you're relying on
probability, because you don't
know what's going on--
predictive non-determinism.
OK, and that's the way we're
going to deal with a lot of
things going on for the
rest of the semester.
We'll look at a lot of examples
where we have to act
as if things are
non-deterministic.
And that gets us to this notion
of what mathematicians
call stochastic processes.
A process is stochastic if it's
next state depends on
both the previous states and
some random element.
So now what I'm going to do is
pick up one of these coins,
flip it in the air, put it down,
and ask, again, about
the state of these
three coins.
It depends upon the previous
state, because these two coins
have the same value they had in
the previous state, plus a
stochastic element, a
probabilistic element, a
random element--
the value of that coin,
which I just flipped.
OK, most programming languages,
including Python,
include simple ways to write
programs that use randomness.
As we'll see, as we've already
seen in Python with our
drunkard's walk, we use the
function random.choice, which,
given a set of values
at random, chose
one of those values.
That function and almost all
of the other functions in
Python that involve randomness
are implemented using
something called
random.random.
This function generates a random
float that's greater
than 0 and no greater than 1.0,
So you get one of the
infinite or seemingly infinite
number of floating point
values that are greater than
0 and no greater than 1.
So let's go look at
another example of
the stochastic process.
We're going to look
at throwing dice.
So I've got something called
rollDie, which chooses a value
between 1 and 6.
For those of you who have
never gambled with
dice, it's a cube.
You roll it, and it has a value
between 1 and 6 that
shows up at random.
And then I've got this little
program called testRoll that
rolls a bunch of dice and
comes up with an answer.
All right, so let's
see what happens.
Actually, before we do that,
let me ask you--
we can look at a question.
Imagine I roll it, and
I run it some large
number of times, 10.
Would you expect to
see the value--
more likely see that value or
might more likely see a value
that looks like this.
Which of these values is more
likely to come up from my
random rolls of the die?
Well when I take a vote--
if I take a vote--
historically in this class, this
strikes people as more
likely to happen than this.
But it's a trick question,
because as it happens, they're
equally likely.
And the reason they're equally
likely is each roll is
independent of the
previous rolls.
And as we'll see in our
excursion in probability and
randomness, independence is a
very important assumption.
In a stochastic process, two
events are independent if the
outcome of one event has
no influence on the
outcome of the other.
The events are independent if
the outcome of one event has
no influence on the outcome
of the other.
So it's a bit easier to think
about this, maybe, if we
simplify the situation for the
moment to think about flipping
coins, which have either heads
or tails, and I'll look at the
value 0 or 1 as the
examples there.
That means I can use--
I have a binary die
for some reason.
So as we've seen before, if I
flip a coin ten times, how
many different possibilities,
sequences
of 0 and 1 are there?
Well we've seen this kind of
thing a lot of times already
this semester.
There are 2 to the 10 binary
numbers of 10 digits, so we
know that there are 2 to
the 10 possibilities.
Each of these 2 to the 10
possibilities are equally likely.
So the number in which I have
all 0's is no more likely than
the number of all 1's, is
no more likely than some
seemingly random combinations
of 0 and 1.
So it's a very small
probability.
So what's the probability
of getting all 1's?
It's 1 out of 2 to the 10.
What's the probability
of getting all 0's?
1 out of 2 to the 10.
What's the probability of any
combination you would happen
to pick of 0's and 1's?
1 over 2 to the 10.
I know I'm belaboring this
point, but the point I want to
make is that when we talk about
some result having a
particular probability, we are
asking, essentially, the
question, what fraction of the
possible results have the
property we're testing for.
So I ask what property
are all 1's.
I'm saying what fraction
If I say well, the properties
are exactly four 1's.
What fraction of these numbers
have exactly four 1's in them?
Whatever I want.
So probabilities will
always be fractions.
That's important because it
means that when we talk about
the probability of some event
occurring, we know it has to
be somewhere between 0 and 1.
Probabilities are never
less than 0.
They're never more than 1.
Cannot happen, guaranteed
to happen, usually
somewhere in between.
All right, that's the key
thing to remember when
thinking about probabilities.
Suppose I want to ask, what's
the probability of getting
some sequence of coin flips
other than all 1's.
Well I know the probability of
getting all 1's is 1 out of 2
to the 10th.
I know the probability
of getting some
sequence of flips is 1.
It's certain I'll get one
of those numbers.
So the answer is the probability
of not getting all
1's is 1 minus 1 over
2 to the 10th.
This is an important
trick to remember.
Typically we have two ways of
computing probabilities.
We can either compute it
directly, as I did when I
computed the probability of
getting all 1's, or we can
compute the probability of
something not happening by
subtracting one probability
from another,
this 1 minus trick.
And so you'll see me using
this formulation a lot of
times, And we'll talk as we
go forward about when
you do it which way.
All right so let's go back,
finally, to our six-sided die.
How many sequences are there
of length 10 for that?
2 to the 10th?
No.
6 to the 10th.
Because unlike the coin where
we only had 2 possibilities,
we now have 6 possibilities.
So there are 6 to the 10th
different sequences of rolls I
could get, quite a few.
So the probability of getting 10
consecutive 1's is 1 over 6
to the 10th.
And of course, the probability
of getting this sequence,
here, is also 1 over 6 to
the 10th, so we see
that they are equal.
OK, we're going to spend a lot
more time on probability and
randomized and stochastic
algorithms.
But before I do that, I want to
take a brief digression and
return to the topic we looked
at a little earlier this
morning, which was data
visualization, plotting.
I want to do this
for two reasons.
One, it's really important.
It's something that all of us
do a lot of in the course of
our work, but it also will just
make it a lot easier for
me to talk about probability
and stochastics when I can
draw some pretty pictures to
illustrate what's going on.
Now many people, most of us,
probably, when we're writing
code to do something, focus on
writing programs that perform
some complicated analysis
of the data,
and then print something.
We don't spend enough time, I
think, worrying about how the
results of our analyses are
presented so that somebody
else can make sense of them, or
in fact, we can understand
them better ourselves.
Sometimes text is the best way,
but sometimes there's a
lot of truth to the Chinese
proverb that a picture's
meaning can express
10,000 words.
Now most of us, sort
of, believe this.
Why don't we do it?
Well because in most programming
languages, it's
hard to draw pretty pictures.
One of the reasons we use
Python in this class is
because in Python, it's easy to
draw pretty pictures or, at
least, to make plots.
Why is that?
It's because somebody--
not me--
went to the trouble of building
something called PyLab.
PyLab is a Python library that
provides many of the
facilities of something
called MATLAB.
If you're an MIT student, the
probability of your graduating
without using MATLAB
is very low.
It is something people
use a lot.
It's not my favorite programming
language.
It has its utility.
I like Python, because
it brings--
a lot of the features of MATLAB
are easy to use in a
programming language that
I find much more
convivial than MATLAB.
All right I'm not going to give
you a complete tutorial
for PyLab here.
It would take a long time,
and it would be boring.
Instead I'm going to give you
a few examples, and in fact,
focus primarily on the plotting
capabilities.
And the good news is the
plotting capabilities in PyLab
are almost identical to those in
MATLAB, so if you learn how
to do it here, you'll already
know how to do it here.
For details you should
take a look at--
let me make sure I write
this correctly--
this website,
matplotlib.sourceforge.net,
and it's a very nicely put
together website that will
give you all of the capabilities
of plotting.
Also you'll find in the class
website, I've written a little
chapter of a book about how to
do this sort of thing, and you
may also find that helpful.
I should point out that PyLab
is not part of the standard
Python distribution.
It has to be installed on your
computer, and again, there are
instructions about how
to do this posted
on the class website.
All right let's start with
something very simple.
We'll look at that, here.
I'm beginning by importing.
I'll import PyLab.
You have to import
it to use it.
And then I'm going to
plot two things.
So what I want to observe,
here, is I'm
going to plot two vectors--
the vector 1, 2, 3, 4 and
the vector 1, 2, 3, 4.
These are the x-coordinates.
These are the y-coordinates.
So we'll get a two-dimensional
plot, x versus y.
And it's very important that
these two vectors be of the
same length.
Doubtless when you're using this
in your problem sets, you
will screw up and you'll get
an error message, which you
will have a hard time
interpreting, but what it
probably is going to boil down
to is you've done something
wrong, and you're plotting
things that are
not the same length.
After I plot these two things,
I'm going to type
"pyLab.show," which will
put the plots up
for us to look at.
So let's do that now.
So the first plot in
our straight line--
1 versus 1, 2 versus 2, 3
versus 3, 4 versus 4--
got that.
Then it plotted this rather
funny looking zigzag we saw,
kind of just randomly chosen
in the other one.
And the plots will always look
something like this.
I should mention, if we go look
at the code, pyLab.show--
if I haven't said that, the plot
would not have appeared
on my screen.
PyLab would have produced it,
but not displayed it.
You may think that's silly,
but in fact it's useful,
because most of the time when
I'm writing programs that do
plotting, I don't want to
see them on my screen.
I'm producing a whole bunch of
plots, and I'm going to write
them to files that I will then
look at later or include in a
paper or a lecture or something,
so it makes me say
that I want to see it.
I should point out, depending
upon your operating system, it
can be pretty annoying, because
if you try and do this
twice in your code, something
bad can happen.
The code can hang.
Therefore, you should
only execute
pyLab.show once per program.
And it should always be the
last thing you executed,
because once you execute
pyLab.show, the program will
stop running, essentially.
It's annoying.
I wish it weren't that
way, but it is.
So live with it.
All right let's go look back
at our graph, our plot.
At the top is a title.
This is the default title.
It says figure 1.
Later we'll see that I could
have given it a much better
title than that.
Then it's got the values of the
x and y-axes and a bunch
of things down at the bottom
that we could point out.
You can zoom in on the plots,
using that or zoom out.
You can use this funny icon.
It happens to be a floppy disk
icon, something that probably
most of you have never seen.
Congratulations if you've never
seen a floppy disk.
Your life is better than
it would be had you had
to deal with them.
But that's used for saving
them to a file.
You can move around in it.
You can get back to what the
original figure was, a whole
bunch of useful things.
I suggest you just bring this
up and play with it.
One of the things I should
mention here is you'll note
that when I produced this,
I only use four points--
1, 2, 3, and 4, say,
for this one.
Yet it looks as if I have
a continuous plot.
You know, it claims that
1.5 and 1.5 match.
This can be very deceptive,
as we'll see later on, and
probably it might have been
better for me to plot not
lines here, but points,
indicating there are only four
points in this graph.
It's more apparent here, where
we see this funny looking
zigzag, implying some
complicated relationship
amongst the points,
which, actually,
probably doesn't exist.
And again later on we'll
see ways to avoid that.
OK.
It is, of course, possible to
produce more than one figure.
So let's look at this.
We'll comment this piece
out for now.
And we'll run this code.
So this says I want to plot
something on a figure I'm
calling figure 1, as before,
And then I'm going to
go to figure 2.
So now instead of plotting
both of these on the same
figure, I'm going to put them
on separate figures.
And then pyLab.savefigure will,
actually, create a file
in the directory in which I'm
running the program and save
it-- called firstsaved And then
this will be secondsaved.
And now I can run it.
And now I have two figures--
figure 1, as before--
well not quite as before,
a different figure--
and figure 2.
Again, nothing very
magical there.
And if we look in my directory,
we should see, I
hope, firstsaved and
secondsaved, so if we look at
secondsaved, we'll
see, there it is.
And just to show that I'm not
cheating, you can notice that
the time stamp is today at 10:34
AM, which happens to be
when I'm giving this
particular lecture.
All right you can put that
away now and continue.
Now what I want you to notice
is the last one.
I just gave it one argument--
5, 6, 7 and 10.
And if we look at what
it plotted--
actually, I think I put that
in figure 1, didn't I?
You'll see, here it is.
And it's made up some values
for the x-axis.
If you only give it one set of
values, it assumes it's the
y-axis, and it finds values.
All right now what values
is it going to
choose for the x-axis?
Well this is Python, so
surprise, surprise, the first
value is 0, 1, 2, and 3.
It's how I get the
four values.
Now we could look at another
example, a slightly more
interesting one.
Comment this out, so we don't
look at the boring stuff over
and over again.
I've written a little program
to calculate interest.
So I'm going to start with an
initial principal, here, of
1,000, an interest rate
of 5%, 20 years, and
just do compound interest.
This, you all would know
how to write this.
And I'm going to plot it
and see what we get.
All right so what we have--
something here, which, sort
of, shows the kind of
beautiful growth you get with
compound interest, what the
finance people call the magic
of compounding, which will
make us all rich in principle,
until we see what the
markets really do.
But at any rate, for now we can
look at it, and it looks
very pretty.
But I don't know
what it means.
I look and say, "oh, its figure
1." Well that's not
very informative, and x goes
from 0 to 20, but if I haven't
told you, you wouldn't
know what that meant.
And y from 10,000 up to
28,000, but again, you
wouldn't know what that means.
We see this all the time.
It's not a good thing.
It's a bad thing, in fact.
All plots should have
informative titles, and all
axes should be labeled.
I can't tell you the number of
times I've had a graduate
student show up in my office,
having worked for weeks
producing some data, put a plot
on my desk, and say, look
at this, isn't it great.
And I say, I have no
idea what it means.
And sometimes, I'll say, well
what is the y-axis, and they
end up scratching their head.
They're not quite sure.
You've got to label your axes.
You've got to put a title.
You've got to give the
person a break.
Well how do we do that?
Well it's pretty simple.
So here's this code.
So I just want to get rid of
the old graphs, because
sometimes if you look at them,
it causes you problems.
Because it's now hung.
It won't continue until
I get rid of it.
Now my shell is back.
So pyLab.title just says, OK,
I'm going to call it 5%
growth, compounded annually.
Notice that I've put in that
it's 5% interest rate and that
I'm compounding it
annually, not
semi-annually or quarterly.
The x-axis is going to be the
years of compounding and the
y-axis, the value of the
principle in dollars.
So now it's the same
curve, but a far
more informative picture.
All right here's where
I want to stop today.
We're going to come back to this
topic, in probably more
detail than you want, and spend
quite a lot of time
talking about how do we produce
beautiful plots, and
more importantly, how do we
produce plots that are,
actually, meaningful to
those reading them.
Thanks a lot.
I'll see you in the
next lecture.